[Music]
the next morning I reached the frontier
town of MacOS
[Music]
situated in the middle of the jungle
Maka's was built as an outpost over 400
years ago
it was here in the 1920s Catholic
missionaries sought to restrain aspects
of the indigenous culture the schwa were
resistant to losing their identity and
particularly reluctant to stop making
senses I've come to a Catholic seminary
to find out how one person was involved
in putting a stop to head-shrinking in
the 1960s how did you explain to the
schwa that they must stop taking
vengeance themselves with Sansa yeah dos
a nosotros colo camos su cultura como
Antigua testamento ISA Matar al criminal
oho poro codeine t4 diente esta en toda
la vía cuando se do se hace hombre sin
karna no M where a la Cruz de si no
perdóname por que no sabe lo que hace no
entonces la una nueva ley que aqui para
donar elenimia
like a Matar sausages by incorporating
schwab beliefs with the New Testament
the Padre feels he helped put an end to
head shrinking in the area have you
personally witnessed a Samsa ceremonie
de Tonto mana no pero la misma ella
Borachio la Seco El mono Perez Oso ha
entonces de todo el mismo ritual dances
quasi listen to the Padres description
I'm able to build up a clearer picture
of how the whole process may have looked
firstly the back of the head would be
open
the skin is sliced free from the skull
care is taken not to damage the facial
features
the skull and remaining flesh is removed
[Music]
the skin is then boiled in water for
half an hour any longer and the hair may
fall out
after being dried in the Sun the skin is
turned inside out any unwanted tissue is
scraped off
a sac shape is formed with the skin and
hot stones are used to burn off the fat
inside hot sand is added to reach the
fat in hard-to-get-to places such as the
nose and lips
the head taker massages the skin to help
the drying process and produce the head
shape once again
the process will be repeated and can
take up to six days until the head is a
quarter of its original size the warrior
must now make sure there is no revenge
attack from the dead man's soul firstly
the eyes are sewn shut
preventing the victims spirit from
seeing out wooden pins are placed
through the lips and lashed together
with string this stops the soul from
asking for their death to be avenged
the warrior is now safely while the soul
within will remain in the abyss